في ضمن الاطار هارتس تنقل ان يجب يجب
التحقيق ان كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد
استخدم الغاز السام في الانفاق وقتل ثلاثه
من الرهائن اذا هو تساؤل تطرحه هرتس
وسنتابع تفاصيله وتفاصيل اخرى تتعلق
بالصفقه التي رفض فيها نتنياهو شرطه الشرط
الذي ورد فيها مع مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري من رام الله
وليد اولا ما جاء بخ خصوص ما نشرتها ارتس
قبل لحظات ومنقول عن والده احد
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين الذين قتلوا في
الانفاق والتي تقول ان معلوماتها بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد ضخ غازات سامه ولذلك
تسبب بقتل ابنها هذا الموضوع من مواضيع
كثيره تثير الشارع الاسرائيلي تحديدا ذوي
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
والاسرائيليون بهذا الشان يمكن القول منق
منا بين من يؤيد نتنياهو ومن يعارض
نتنياهو بتفاوت النسب من يؤيد نتنياهو
يقول بانه يجب المضي في هذه الحرب او ما
يسمونه بالضغط العسكري من اجل الوصول الى
الافراج عن الاسرائيليين المحتجزين ومن
يعارض نتنياهو وهم كثر و ومن ضمنهم الذوي
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين يطالبون وايضا
داخل المجلس الحرب يطالبون بالذهاب الى
صفقه جديده يتم في اطارها الافراج عن جميع
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين لدى حماس والفصائل
الاخرى في قطاع غزه حتى لو كان الثمن الكل
في مقابل الكل بمعنى الافراج عن الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في السجون الاسرائيليه لكن
الخلاف كبير ونتنياهو كان قد حسم موقفه
برفض المنحى الجديد الذي يتحدثون عنه
ويقول انها شروط لحماس بوقف القتال
والانسحاب الى خارج قطاع غزه قبل الدخول
في عمليه الصفقه والتي تتح يتحدث المنحى
الذي تسرب عنها وتعمل عليها الدول الوسيطه
وهي الولايات المتحده وقطر ومصر من ثلاثه
مراحل لكن التقديرات في اسرائيل وقبل
اجتماع مجلس الحرب مساء هذا اليوم تشير
الى انه من حيث المبدا هناك استعداد سواء
لدى اسرائيل او لدى حركه حماس للدخول في
مفاوضات لكنهم يقولون بان الطريق طويل جدا
حتى الوصول الى نتيجه وسيكون طريقا عسيرا
للغايه وفي هذا السياق يتواصل ايضا
احتجاجات ذوي الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
الذين بالامس نصبوا خيمه امام منزل رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو في القدس الغربيه في شارع
غزه بالمناسبه وشارع غزه يسمى وفيه منزل
خاص لنتنياهو
يطالبونه فيه بالذهاب فورا حتى لو كان ذلك
وقفا لاطلاق النار واعاده ابنائهم
واقربائهم من الحجز لدى حركه حماس في غزه
وهناك مظاهره متواصله واعتصامات ايضا في
تل ابيب ولكنها بدات ترفع ايضا شعارات
تطالب باسقاط هذه الحكومه واسقاط نتنياهو